one of the great things that modern
Scholars are perplexed by is why does
everyone have a dragon like there's not
a single human culture anywhere in the
world that doesn't have a dragon
including people who live in places that
don't have
snakes this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to
the symbolic
[Applause]
world so hello everyone we are back with
Richard Roland for another Universal
history episode and this week we are
going to talk about dragons which I'm
sure is going to be of interest to
everybody uh that I know around the
symbolic world so Richard go I know so
many people have been asking for this
for so long that's right and so we
already had a little bit of the Dragon
discussion in the baywolf course that
we've talked about uh quite a bit and so
you could check that out for sure but uh
we'll see when Jonathan says a little
bit what he means is that we actually
talked about dragons for about seven
hours so so I just really want to like
make sure that that we we I wna I want
to properly sell you on the baywolf
class if you haven't already signed up
for that bought that I know it's a
little pricey but it's literally uh
like 20 something hours of Jonathan and
I talking about baywolf like total you
know and along with handouts and
everything else and and we literally
spent at least seven hours talking about
the dragon between the last two classes
that's right and uh if you want to know
the secret connection between the dragon
and the grindel kin for instance it's
not what Neil Gaiman thinks it is um but
if you want to know what it is and there
is a secret connection then uh sign up
for that class and a lot of the things
that we're going to say say about
dragons today we cover in significantly
more depth in the class so what I really
want to happen over the course of the
next few years is is to do some more of
these kinds of classes where I get to go
really deep on things that I'm trying to
summarize in 45 minutes and you know the
really frustrating thing about making
these videos Jonathan is that we'll
record something and then later on I'll
think oh I said that wrong I need to go
back and you know so like when we do the
the the coursework not only do we get to
go deeper and you know we got uh 18 to
20 hours instead of one hour right for a
subject but also I get to like do a lot
more in the in terms of like research
footnotes editing and also you get all
of my like presentation like slides of
notes and stuff like that for those
classes so the b class was the first one
I hope we have some more to introduce
next year oh yeah I for sure Dante the
comedy is going to probably be the next
one we're going to do cuz I'm excited
about doing that as well so I think that
that will be the next one and then we'll
see from there on so Richard how are you
going to start us off with dragons like
we don't even know where to start so I
should have expected this given that
they're dragons you know but uh they
they they turn out to be very difficult
to uh pin down as it were um it
[Music]
were in 2021 my brother met you and I
with the help of cor neelsen of Philip
Carton and introduce all of you to a New
Vision of Storytelling we launched the
God's dog monster graphic novel through
crowdfunding introducing the dog-headed
St Christopher the dragon slang St
George into full view as a new epic
story began the response was astounding
reaching over
$250,000 and ultimately selling out our
first print of the book now book two of
five in this series God's dog Warrior
moves into the meet of this epic story
where our dog-headed stranger must be
integrated must be trained and must
fight the cosmic Stakes behind the story
become clear the character shine and
heart-wrenching choices must be made
book two will surprise you with more
monsters more Giants and a deeper
exploration of the mythology underlying
it all since book one of God's dog I've
also started a publishing company called
symbolic World Press with some amazing
Partners to deal with the Timely
production Printing and shipping of all
future books we've already successfully
published Snow White and the Widow Queen
and will expand our activities rapidly
the money we raise is to build this
whole project and even move towards
other media we now have three full-time
people working with us plus nine artists
six writers collaborating towards at
least 14 upcoming books and all of this
without any outside funding no outside
control
it's all of you making this possible
this is why crowdfunding is so powerful
so on this crowdfunding we've partnered
with professional comic artist Matt Shen
Jesse White Philip ctin and Martin crotz
to bring together God's dog Warrior but
on top of that I'm also introducing an
entirely new comic book series called
the garments of skin which will explore
the L the mythology around God's dog
bring the story Into the Contemporary
world where new hero her es tried to
resist a global system of
control we are at a turning point in
culture a turning point in storytelling
and I know I can count on all of you to
make it possible we have to take back
the Reigns of Storytelling move past The
Gatekeepers and I thank all of you for
trusting us to play a part in that thank
you for backing Gods doog Warrior and
Kickstarter
today
there's this great line from a scholar
that I was reading um on the the subject
of dragons in like an the ancient near
East and ancient Indo European Legends
which is probably where we'll start and
uh she says that you're expecting it to
be like oh it's a a thread and I'll
start pulling the thread and I'll just
be able to chase it from beginning to
the end but it's not like that it's like
a spider web m and you're looking at all
of the threads and you're like well did
this come from this or did this come
from this and did this come from this
and and and it's very difficult to sort
of
Trace like even nail down what a dragon
is because there are certain General
things and that's where we're going to
start in a second there are certain
General things you could say are true
about dragons but
then there are always exceptions to that
so like you could say you know if
there's 10 things that make a dragon
like all dragons have seven out of 10 of
these things right different seven out
of 10 but but then um but then there are
various dragons that are like little
weird exceptions to these rules and I
think that this is going to go a lot
towards uh the way that we think about
the dragon as as a monster right as a
monster as very often something of a
shape shifter right uh something that's
got the ability capacity to kind of
change its shape and actually takes on
different roles in different societies
and then maybe what that means for us
again you know as as always I'm coming
at this from the perspective of a
Christian who um you know and and and so
for us as as Christians the idea of a
serpent or a dragon means something in
particular although it also means other
things that maybe most people haven't
thought about so we'll get into that no
for sure that's been the way that I
would approach it mostly you know for
those who have read I've read a few
articles about it I wrote an article
called the dragons that almost exist
where I discussed the the the
relationship between the dragon and the
monster and that it seemed to be the key
in in in you know the idea of something
which is not fully identified is exactly
what a dragon is and so because of that
it has that shapes shifting quality yeah
yeah so the let me just go over some
things that all dragons or let's most
dragons seem to have in common right the
first is that a dragon is a serpent now
when I say a dragon is a serpent I mean
the the word Dragon itself probably
comes from a very old like early Latin
word which means just a serpent right or
from sorry from a Greek word that means
just a serpent and um it's got It's from
a Proto IND European Ute root word which
has to do with uh the glance right uh
like the like the idea of like a
piercing glance or a deadly glance right
that's the that's the root of that word
and um and of course there are there
even to this day there are plenty of
dragon-like creatures right dragons or
dragon-like creatures whose gaze is one
of the most deadly things things about
them right the Basilisk for instance and
so on now something to say here is that
we have to be really careful about when
we're going back and looking at
dragons um for our purposes we're not
going to
really we're not you have to be really
careful about not treating them as like
different species right there's a kind
of like a modern tendency that has its
you know as its apoy like the the the D
D and D monster manual right where it's
like you've got all these different
kinds of dragons and then these other
kinds of like Dragon Light creatures and
they're all sort of different a
different species with a different stat
block and a different you know and uh so
that sometimes if you if you come at
this stuff from that modern perspective
you end up getting a little tripped up
on things that that really would just
not have been a difficult thing for
somebody in the ancient world uh so for
instance if you look at a a Persian
Dragon right if you look at artwork of a
Persian Dragon it looks exactly like a
Chinese dragon yeah yeah now if you're
coming at this from a modern perspective
you'd say well the Persians had one word
for dragons and the Chinese had this
other word that we translate as dragon
and so are they really the same creature
but you can just look at the artwork
like contemporary Persian Chinese
artwork and say yeah it's definitely the
same same creature like no Chinese
person traveling in Persia which is a
thing that happened by the way uh no
Chinese person traveling in Persia in
the Iron Age would have looked at a
picture of a of a Persian dragon and
said oh I don't know that is just it's
not it's not how it goes
so most dragons seem to be composite
creatures now I I said that all dragons
are serpents right or at least most
dragons are serpent actually most
dragons seem to be composite creatures
but one the main ingredient is always
serpent put it that way right well
that's because by the way that's
important to to to state because first
of all that's what makes it a monster
right a monster is a hybrid because it
doesn't have a category attributed only
to itself so when you you look at a
hybrid or when you look at a monster
what you're seeing is things that in
your estimation don't have are taken
from other places and are stuck together
into one thing that's actually an
experience of hybridity in general it's
not just related to monsters it can help
us understand what monsters are but that
is also what a snake is a snake is a
being that can be in two places at once
it's one of the only ones right because
it it does this yeah yeah yeah and it's
a and it's a it's a being that also
transforms itself by shedding its outer
appearance and kind of reconstituting
its its outer appearance so the idea of
the of the snake that sheds its skin
means that there's a relationship
between hybridity monstrosity and change
because change is exactly when something
loses its identity especially kind
transformational change loses its
identity and then is in the process of
becoming something else and in that
middle space between the what it used to
be and what it's becoming now there's a
kind of fluidity that that that appears
and that is what accounts for monsters
that's why we used to say that the word
monster means a sign right it's a it's a
sign that something that thing yeah
something's happening like that that
things are not going to be the same
anymore and that's what the sign of
hybridity uh reveals to us and this is
precisely why it's so difficult to talk
about a dragon or even to trace like one
of the great things that modern Scholars
are perplexed by is why does everyone
have a dragon like there's not a single
human culture anywhere in the world that
has a that doesn't have a dragon
including people who live in places that
don't have
snakes right and and so it's one of
these things where people are always
trying to sort of answer the question
like why does everybody have a dragon
and yeah the dragons they're all a
little bit different depending on where
you live if you live near the water
maybe it's a sea serpent or like a sea
dragon kind of a thing right but but you
know if you live you know so so what's
going on there and so modern Scholars
have these
a bu of f different theories for this
say oh well it's dinosaur bones now to
be
completely every time before the 19th
century anybody ever dug up dinosaur
bones which happened all the time for
instance lots of dinosaur bones in China
when people dug up dinosaur bones in
China what did they call them Dragon
they said these are dragon bones of
course and in fact that dragon bone like
powdered dragon bone is an important
element uh uh uh uh ingredient in
traditional Chinese medicine you know
it's just like fossilized dinosaur bones
right um uh dragon bones and uh same
thing same thing in the British Isles
same thing in in anywhere that
somebody's dug up dragon uh dinosaur
bones they've said oh these obviously
you know that's true I know I know I'm
trying to I'm trying to bring people
along with us Jonathan trying to
accommodate for the the modern world I I
understand yeah I'm trying to bring
people along with us um it's actually
yeah it's much easier just to say
they're dragon bones right so um and
actually what's really fun is that
uh all of these uh like the some of the
more recent reconstructions of what
these various different uh uh dinosaurs
might have actually looked like they're
like well maybe they had feathers and
maybe they had this maybe they had this
and they start they keep looking more
and more like dragons and I'm like just
waiting I'm just waiting for somebody to
notice you know that's right it's that
is actually I noticed that too I thought
you know they used to make fun of the
medievals for their dragon category and
now you look at a medieval manuscript
and you look at modern reconstructions
and you're like ah they got it better
than a lot of the you know early 20th
century gray like those gray lizards
that they that they that they did yeah
uh okay so anyway all this to say uh I
just want to say one thing about the
Dragon Balls actually so this is
important this is important to
understanding in a meta way is that the
fact that the dragon manifests itself as
a residue of something which is
forgotten is also part of what a dragon
is manifesting like an ancient world
that we know longer have access to and
that is and is kind of manifesting
itself as a kind of chaos broken residue
a remainder of an ancient world these
are all the types of symbolism that we
need to gather together when we think of
what a dragon is there's a
um uh one one of my other favorite
theories from Modern Scholars about this
you know people who like to think of
things in predominantly like
evolutionary terms this is the Jordan
Peterson strategy is the idea that um
the idea that well maybe it's because
we're descended from monkeys and the
monkeys were afraid of snakes and so now
we're afraid of like I don't know just
like goofy goofy stuff you know this is
really Jordan's Jordan's Theory like is
that that that that that it's a in some
ways our fear of snakes uh is a
predetermined thing like it's not
something learned it's actually
biologically inscribed in us and so and
so that's why we have a mythological
image of a snake that keeps manifesting
itself so the the Big Challenge to this
is uh is that of course many people are
not afraid of snakes uh a lot of people
like them uh but also like not every
like not everybody is afraid of dragons
either like we'll we'll get to that
right uh different cultures have kind of
different ways of encountering or
dealing with Dragons so like I I don't
know uh yeah I I'm I'm not totally I'm
not totally Satisfied by that theory for
lots of reasons I guess let me let me
give the devilit do as Jordan himself
say yeah is that he said that the the
relationship between the snake is not
just a fear it's fear and Fascination it
has to be both because when the ape sees
the snake it will be afraid of it but it
will stare at it like it'll stare at it
for like hours because it's trying to
figure out what's going on and so this
relationship between fear and
Fascination is one that that he talks
about but the thing is that let's say
how can I say this the best description
of a dragon like the best discussion
about dragon has to do with our
experience of of the category rather
than the mechanical description right of
how it mechanically came about no
whatever that is like we're not apes and
we don't have to deal with we don't live
in trees and we don't have to deal with
snakes and so the idea that you would
tell me that that's the origin of this
it's like that doesn't mean anything it
doesn't it doesn't it doesn't enter into
my categories of meaning it doesn't
enter into the fact that that you know a
child will will will draw a snake like
that a that some something there's
something primordial about and that it
happens in every culture like that's a
there's are better ways to approach that
and I think the universal history
approach is a better one that to make
sense of it so yeah there you go yeah
that that was good and I appreciate you
explaining that side of things to me a
little more because um actually I don't
know if you've ever seen like a weasel
or a ferret hunt a a rabbit or or some
kind of a rodent but they actually do
like sort of like a little dance that
hypnotizes the the the rabbit where the
rabbit's like fascinated can't look away
yeah and then the weasel kills it so
anyway it's like mgle the snake and
mowgly that was a great in the Disney
the Disney that was that was a wonderful
Insight because it's not in the book but
it's like a wonderful it is well it is
in the book except that Kai Kai the rock
python in the in the book is is mowgli's
friend yeah um and so actually in the in
the book uh he's in the like the city of
the the the bandal log the the monkeys
right yeah and this the snake is the one
that saves him from the monkeys but he's
saves him from the monkeys by basically
hypnotizing the monkeys until they
basically walk into his Jaws but he's
mowgli's friend in the in the books so
that's the that's the big difference but
anyway I love Roger kitling um okay so
let's get back to dragons um uh so
dragons are serpents this the first
thing we can say about them but that
they have this element of hybridity so
dragons are very rarely I once say never
but they're very rarely just a serpent
and in fact if you go and look at
mythological carvings we'll talk about
some of these these dragons that are
killed by Thunder gods in Indo-European
and then later in Semitic mythologies
ancient neares mythologies but if you go
look at iconographic depictions of the
serpent the serpent is almost never
actually
shown uh uh almost so so VRA the the the
serpent uh in the um in the rigveda
right who is killed by Indra the the
sort of the great hero of the Epic um
he's he's he's almost never depicted as
just a serpent he's usually like a some
kind of a serpent human hybrid and
that's pretty normal like the the F
farther back you go the oldest Dragon
myths are usually actually depicting
some kind of a serpent human hybrid
there's a Persian variant of this where
he has uh it's a man but he has three
heads and two of the heads are serpent
heads um and um you know and then of
course you're various like you know
human upper body Serpentine lower half
or vice versa right you have that as you
have that as well so yeah you see that
everywhere but it's important to
understand though that this
manifestation has to be extended for
example into the serpent in the garden
because a serpent that speaks is already
a serpent that's not quite a serpent is
already something that is humanlike you
could say right uh even if though it
doesn't necessarily physically appear
that way yeah and and so a lot of times
you'll have various dragons or
dragon-like creatures which uh we're
just going to call dragons for purposes
of what we're doing today that will have
Serpentine features but then they'll
also have uh features from lion or uh
very commonly in um uh Chinese dragons
which I'm going to blow everybody's mind
about in a moment so just stay tuned for
that people but Chinese dragons often
have the a almost always have antlers
like a deer um as a and you know feet
like a lion and all these other parts so
um and actually there's a lot of
traditional accounts and depictions of
Chinese and other Asian dragons Far
Eastern dragons um there's a lot of
symbolism that's you know that they they
read a lot of symbolism into the the
numbers of the scales or the numbers of
the dots on the back of you know and so
on so like all of these features are
actually very important for
understanding uh those creatures and
that the dragons in those cultures but
uh so the second thing we could say
about dragons is that dragons are almost
always a guardian of some kind um and
the things that dragons traditionally
guard or you could say hoard um because
hoarding is like the the Dark Side of of
guarding something um uh but the things
that dragons almost are always guarding
or hoarding is water uh in almost every
culture and then everything else that
you have a dragon hoarding later on Ian
famously in Western Europe dragons sit
on Treasure right but that's that's
because of certain developments a little
bit later on which we'll talk about yeah
they also kidnap women yes yeah you St
George story they so we have to think of
it as a kind of hoarding where he takes
the virgin and keeps her and then she
has to be freed well and but also the
the keeping of the woman is associated
with so this is the thing they Guard
water but if you really think about the
significance of guarding water it
actually goes back to this idea of the
serpent as the guardian of paradise um
so if people want to get more into this
side of things you can go listen to the
Lord of spirits episode on The Serpent
and the devil and all that stuff um one
of the things they talk about is the the
relationship of the serpent in Genesis
to the idea of the sarra the sarra which
is you know a winged fiery serpent um
also a category of Angel right um but
the fiery uh the the fiery uh it's a
really old word I think it well it's a
really old word and the fiery originally
has to do with like the the the sting
like the the poison the Venom the Venom
of the of the serpent um but this idea
that this idea that the serpent you know
was was supposed to be sort of the
Guardian of paradise and then that
becomes obviously corrupted uh
um but some other places that this
manifest just for instance is um well
okay so the thing to say about Paradise
is that paradise is a place where water
comes from right actually first and
foremost this is the first thing that we
know about Eden yeah is that it has four
rivers coming out of it right and so if
you think about well how do you have
four rivers coming out of it in four
different cardinal directions well the
only way you can do that is if you're at
elevation and there's a spring and then
the water's flowing in each direction
from the spring right so that's that's
what that's what Paradise is right it's
a place where water flows from right and
so the the idea of of kind of like
guarding Paradise or is related to this
idea of guarding the water or hoarding
the water and
so um this this shows up in uh most most
famously for instance all the Greek
dragons are are water Guardians um so
the uh the the the python that Apollo
kills uh the uh the Nan Hydra I mean I
mean Hydra itself like is just means
water right so a Hydra if you're looking
at if you're looking at things through
like a modern again hate to ragon D and
D here but like through that modern D
and D lens you're like oh a hyra that's
a different creature than a drag no it's
it's just a dragon right but this
particular dragon has multiple heads and
uh but it guards this particular body of
water right um
and uh but yes all the all the all the
biggest uh uh Greek culture Heroes
starting with Apollo and orus um
are famous for killing monsters but but
the like the original Monster you know
starting with Apollo and orus is this
dragon or the serpent that guards a body
of water right and we can think about
the importance of water in the ancient
world and actually it's still its
importance in our world today I it's
easy to take for granted because I turn
on the tap and the water comes out
although actually they had the water
shut off to uh for our uh uh to our
street earlier this week because they
were doing some some repairs to a pipe
down the road and um uh that that sense
of like turning on the tap and the water
doesn't come out and that just like
moment of of like really primordial
Panic that sits in it's like wait why
don't we have water why don't we have
water you know and it was all fine it
was good and but it's one of those
things where uh uh water is so essential
it's so completely essential to life
right and that uh you know again that's
the most important feature we always
think of like the garden of the fruit
and the trees and everything for obvious
reasons but the most important you know
feature of paradise is is the fact that
this is a source of water this is where
the water comes from and this is why the
whole the whole idea of the the water
coming from the Throne of God in the
apocalypse right that's that's what
that's about and in St Ephraim and in a
lot of the medieval cosmology the idea
was in some ways that all the water came
from Eden you know like that the the
four rivers basically watered the entire
world until they ran into the ocean so
yeah for people who don't know St
Ephraim who is a fourth Century Church
Father Syrian poet uh definitely one of
my favorite uh uh Church fathers um but
he uh he's very clear in his hymns on
Paradise and his commentary in Genesis
he's very very clear that he doesn't
believe that uh Eden is like a
terrestrial site it's not on Earth it's
sort of above the Earth and you have all
the water of the world I mean those four
rivers mentioned in Genesis as most
people probably know um are are the four
Great Rivers of ancient civilization
that's that's what's significant about
them is like those those four rivers in
the in the understanding of the ancient
near East like Mesopotamia and Levant
those four rivers are the source of of
life and civilization in the ancient
world so so you've got those four rivers
kind of flowing down from Paradise into
the terrestrial world yeah um so yeah so
dragons usually guard watch over protect
bodies of water and they can either do
this in a friendly helpful way um so
there are such things as I'm not going
to say safe dragons but but sometimes
helpful or friendly dragons right
sometimes you can actually get what you
want from a dragon under certain
circumstances um but um and uh and then
other cases they hoard all of the waters
so that nobody gets them um so then the
the third thing that we could say about
dragons is that they
um and there are this is where we start
getting into some more exceptions but
typically speaking uh the dragon has an
enemy and the original enemy the sort of
primordial enemy of the Dragon is the
bull um the bull or really the Thunder
God right who's usually associated with
a bull um and I'll give some examples of
this uh at this point is probably a good
chance to go into
them um so uh uh in the in the oldest
stories and one of the things that we
talked about in the baywolf class is
that uh there are um there are Scholars
who believe so for instance uh there is
a um there's a book by Calbert Watkins
called how to kill a dragon um which is
a a really deep study in Indo-European
Poetics we read from some of it in the
baywolf class and I would just say if
anybody out there wants to understand
what philology is and how it works and
what you would use it for and the way
that you kind of follow formulas and
words as they develop and get reused
again over and over again in in stories
over a really long period of time that
book is a is a really good uh it's a
really good introduction to the subject
uh but basically what he argues in there
is that the uh is that the original
story at least for Indo-European
languages the original story is hero
slay serpent right the hero slays a
serpent and the hero in these really old
stories is almost always a um either
Thunder God or the son of a Thunder God
now as as Dragon slang stories kind
of
um reproduce themselves I don't know how
else to say it you know then eventually
eventually you know the Thunder God part
will kind of will kind of drop out but
even then the idea of like a father and
son pair or an uncle nephew pair
sometimes uh being involved in the
slaying of of the Dragon is still kind
of the typical the typical pattern of
the story so yeah which gets carried by
the way all which gets carried all the
way into the story of St Michael killing
the dragon in a kind of transformed way
but this idea that you know some a
principality from heaven like a kind of
War principality from heaven will it
will be the one to finally slay the big
dragon yeah yeah so uh let me give some
examples real quick from some really old
Indo-European stories so for people who
don't know indoan languages are uh the
languages
of with some except ceptions some some
some things like that we could asterisk
that are not indoan languages but almost
every language that you find in India
and in um what is now uh Iran like the
sort of the Iranian step and then in
Europe are Indo-European languages that
is they are descended from the same
group uh the same family of languages
that go kind of go all the way back and
there are certain elements of induran
society which in places as far apart as
Ireland and India yeah develop in the
same way because they have the same
Roots right and that and that's why so
there is kind of a common uh uh language
group and and and then because of that a
common culture so um one of the earliest
Indo-European dragons or serpents that
we have is uh I mentioned a moment ago
VRA VRA is a dragon or a demon in the
form of a dragon um uh who in the rig
Veda takes all of the Waters of uh uh of
all the rivers in the world hoardes them
under a mountain right so this is of
course disastrous for the world there's
no fresh water no fertile river valleys
and this means that the ancient hero
Indra who uh uh sorry this means that
ancient agrarian societies of the Indian
subcontinent would be would have
completely collapsed right without water
you don't have anything so um he's slain
by the hero Indra who slays him with a
thunderbolt crafted for him by the craft
God of Tash tree I think and um that
that name Tash tree is uh has a lot of
permutations um it shows up in like
hittite stuff for instance also in
induran language and uh but in every
kind of permutation uh that that that
he's the guy usually that makes the
Thunderbolt not always but in in most
cases let's say um is that the weapon
you see in Indian culture like the
double Trident kind of weapon yeah so I
should explain that a a a trident is a
thunderbolt yeah I don't know how people
uh how many people know this or have
thought about this um and I think that
it's because thanks to Disney and other
things uh we like we associate associate
a trident with Poseidon you know and the
sea but a trident is a it's it's
lightning right that for branches right
that so a trident is a thunderbolt and
and the the typical weapon of the storm
God is a trident Thunderbolt yeah so uh
that's what Zeus used the the Greek
version of this is when Zeus kills
Typhon uh who's the Greek Titan who is a
serpent monster father monsters Etc um
it uses the Thunderbolt but the
Thunderbolt is really a trident like if
you're imagining you know Poseidon has a
trident and then Zeus has like this
Jagged thing you know that looks like a
piece of cartoon lightning that's not
actually that's not actually how they
depicted it so anyway
um so uh uh so he kills uh he kills uh
rra and
um this you know and this is the this is
the basic pattern of of the myth um and
uh it shows up in the myth the hittite
story actually probably the oldest
recorded version that we have of this
particular myth is the myth of the
hittite uh uh God
ilanka
and it's a little tenuous like I said uh
would you try to trace Dragon Stories
and how they develop over time you think
it's going to be like I'll just start
pulling this thread and see where it
goes but it it's the spider web but but
we just say that the oldest Dragon slang
stories that have are found in Kuna form
uh but they're they're written in
hittite or in Lan which would have been
like the language probably spoken by the
Trojans right the Trojans were
essentially Hittites um and uh who had a
very Who had who had a vast Empire and
some of these these stories go back to I
think the earliest ones that we have we
can reliably date to something like the
16th be uh uh uh Century BC something
like that like really old or maybe a
little bit older than that and um they
seem to have made their way VIA era via
um kind of uh contact with the north of
the Levant they seem to have made their
way eventually into Mesopotamia so in
Mesopotamian Legend you have an anal
Alish which is the the Mesopotamian
creation myth um and it famously of
course you've got you know Sumerian and
Acadian versions of it but uh more
recent research has those as being maybe
slightly younger by a couple of hundred
years than the uh the hittite version so
some people will say that it's
originally a Semitic myth that travels
West and like Northwest and then other
people say it's actually an indoeuropean
myth that originally traveled into the
the near East somehow um it's probably
impossible to say definitively it
doesn't really matter but what all a lot
of these stories have in common not all
of them but what a lot of these stories
have in common is this idea of um that
is is tying it somehow into the idea of
creation right so that the storm God
when he kills the chaos serpent right
he's able to separate uh the land from
the sea right separate the land from the
sea um so this this has this manifests a
lot later on in basically every other
dragon slaying myth that you find that
you'll encounter in either the ancient
near East or uh or Europe and uh so for
instance the the most famous Norse
dragon is fathir fafnir is actually a
dwarf he's a son of a powerful Sorcerer
And after essentially after his family
comes into the possession of a horde of
cursed gold faer drives his brother off
turns himself into a dragon and guards
The Horde himself right and um
eventually Along Comes a guy named
sigard the volsang or in the earlier
versions of the story he has father cund
so there's that fatherson pair that's uh
or sometimes uncle nephew pair that's
really important in these kinds of
stories he slays the dragon with some
help usually from a son or from a nephew
or from somebody who's both a son and a
nephew in the case of
uh in the case of incest MH um and uh he
kills the dragon the way that the dragon
is almost always killed in the Western
European version which is uh instead of
being struck by a ThunderBolt from above
he is stabbed From Below right so that's
how fath is killed that's how B Wolf's
Bane um although if you want to know the
the name of B Wolf's Bane like the name
of the dragon of bolf you can you can go
but listen to the glasses but um uh but
yeah that Dragon uh uh
it's so this seems to be kind of like a
theme in in the sort of like the Western
Northwestern European version of the
story is that the way that you kill a
dragon is you stab it from below yeah um
and um the the significance of fafnir
hoarding gold instead of water is
actually pretty simple to understand
it's that um it's that uh the the the
culture of the Iron Age dramatic North
was not agrarian it was essentially what
what I've described uh elsewhere in the
baywolf class as a pirate economy right
so it works on it works by going and
rating somebody taking their gold and
then using that gold it's a pirate gift
economy using that gold to give gifts to
your retainers which is not the same
thing as paying them it's a it's a
there's a difference but you use it to
give gifts to your retainers who then
give you service right so there's this
reciprocity reciprocal generosity but
you you you have to have gold to be
generous with and there are no gold
mines in in uh in Norway right so you've
got to go get the gold some other way
right so you go raid you know you go do
your Christmas shopping at lindis far
and then you that's that's a joke um
yeah you you you a horrible joke I know
I'm really sorry I'm really sorry
Christmas sharing and Linda is fine I'm
I'm really sorry man yeah see I see your
Northern roots are coming
out trying really hard to to hide all of
that but yeah so you go you go raid
England or you go raid like northern
France before the Normans who were
essentially Vikings right right before
they settled there right you go raid
somebody civilized and then you get
their gold and then use that gold to
keep your economy going so this is why
in bwolf we talk about this in the class
but there's this huge focus on baywolf
on generosity the the king's role as as
ringger and uh uh herode who's the worst
King right he's the archetypical evil
man evil King right the example that
gets brought up over and over again in
the poem his whole deal is that he's
he's stingy because he's like afraid of
what's going to happen in the future
like if I give this away then I won't
have it for later kind of a thing right
and so because of that his kingdom
collapses right and so if you're not
generous then uh then Society collapses
so a way to think about what a dragon is
is that it um at least in some
permutations it Hoards whatever is
necessary for you to exist as a
society
now this is where we get to to this the
kind of like the the but what abouts
right and so one of the things that you
can say definitively is that all the
oldest versions of dragon stories in all
the oldest versions of Dragon Stories
drag the dragon has an enemy the enemy
is usually a Thunder God or somebody
that associated in some way with a
Thunder God um obviously all of this
eventually shows up much later um from
the perspective like the hittite stories
shows up much later in like the Bale
cycle and so on and I will just I will
hear in V against um uh modern Scholars
of the ancient near East so I hope
you're listening folks um uh sometimes
when you read accounts of this and
you're reading about all these Thunder
gods and the dragons they killed and
everything you'll get something like so
these six lines of Cana form allow us to
say all of these things uh with great
certainty about the ancient louan storm
God but then there's this guy in the
this this God in the southern Levant
Yahweh and we just don't know anything
about him he's so perplexing but he
seems to have been some kind of a bull
deity you know but unfortunately nothing
helpful has ever been written about
Yahweh you know like nothing that we can
rely on it's just very aggravating it's
like you get six lines of canor you say
all these things with absolute certainty
but when it comes to the god of the
Bible well obviously we can't trust the
Bible so we got to go to non-biblical
sources for for yeah yeah we need to
find some line of uniform on a broken
tablet somewhere that we don't know what
the context
right yeah so anyway that's my that's my
deep frustration which I was feeling as
I was putting together the notes for our
conversation but yeah but it's this by
the way it's important for Christians at
some point we've understood that it's
like that for everything Christian it's
like you know every Everything Christian
has this well the the people who told
Jesus's story must be lying because they
knew him yeah okay how the hell like how
the hell didn't we get the story it's
like so the people who wrote it because
they're close to it they must be line
because they're trying to make it look
good and so anyways yeah so but this
brings up an important point because the
main thing that we've been doing in
Universal history from the very start is
actually trying to look at these things
like Through The Eyes of the people who
wrote them like yeah take those people
seriously right and U I mean to go back
to uh our last video about the about
Christmas one of the things we uh we I
we kind of mentioned a little bit and
then probably didn't elaborate on enough
for some people it is talking about the
date of Christmas right so this you know
so if you look at if you look at
um lot of early like uh third Century on
uh Christian authors right who are
putting together chronologies December
the 25th is the date that they signed to
the to to the birth of Christ right and
this is even before we have reliable
dates for like some of those Pagan
winter celebrations yeah like like Soul
Invictus and things like that so so um
if we just look at it from the
perspective of the early church this is
when everybody believed Christ Christ
was born right and so the only reason to
reject that as we said is this idea that
it just makes too much sense right or
this idea and this is really what it
comes down to is this idea that if you
find something in
Christianity that is similar to
Something in some other religion it must
other religion has to always have been
the source that's right right it can
never it could never have happened the
other way yeah because you see the same
with the northern uh you know with the
with the Scandinavian stories which is
that you know if there's a resemblance
between Christianity even though
Christians wrote this down if there's a
resemblance between Christianity and
these stories it must be that they
influenc Christianity which is just so
hilarious I I once had somebody really
argue very sincerely with me that um
that the story of Christ crucifixion had
never happened it was just based on the
myth myth of oen hanging himself on the
world tree I like okay but that myth
nobody even came up with that story like
no one had even heard of oen in the
first century ad like he's a late God
you know like he's a very late God in
the north Pantheon like like there's no
way that could be the case his story was
WR literally written a thousand years
later but but by Christians right by
Christians but but this this person just
could not accept the idea that if there
was a similarity yeah that Christianity
might have been like the original the
origin of it so anyway all of this to
say all of this to say um uh what were
we talking we get back to yeah I'm so
sorry I'm so sorry but uh uh so all of
this to say it is it is really important
to actually point out that if you read
the Bible you will
find that there's a lot of Yahweh
killing the dragon kind of stuff going
on in the Old Testament and by the way
also in the New Testament right and um
and this is really deliberate this is
really really deliberate right um
because so many of those passages in the
Psalms or for instance in the book of
Isaiah which talks about uh um Christ uh
it talks about Yahweh killing Lon or
Leviathan right um all of those passages
they they're a
um they have a sort of pical uh point
they're trying to make which is that all
these things that you think about Baal
right or the uh Baal hadat in in
particular right who who's like sort of
the storm God in that in that cycle um
uh all these things that you think are
true about him or his sister or whoever
is supposed to kill Leviathan in the
different versions of that story or that
you think are true about Marduk if it's
the Babylonian version or whatever like
all those things are actually true about
the God of Israel but they're more true
about the God of Israel right because B
swallowed by death but um you know but
but our God will swallow up death that
kind that kind of a thing right and so
when you come across this this
um uh you could say like really
cosmological I don't know the right word
for it uh imagery of of of Yahweh sort
of you riding the clouds and scattering
uh the light lightning like his arrows
and all this different stuff in the
Psalms which is incredibly cool uh
there's no need to be alarmed as that at
that as a Christian right there's no
need to be alarmed at because of
course this is his world this is the
world that he made these things belong
to him and and those particular passages
they do have a certain purpose right
they had a purpose then they also have a
purpose now right uh in in sort of
showing his his his Supremacy over
creation over the waters and many of
Christ's Miracles are actually aimed at
uh in his own lifetime I I think that we
talked you and I talked recently about
this not in a in a recorded conversation
or we were talking about some new
Miracles and uh talking about something
like walking on water right and we think
of that as like kind of um um in English
when when you say so and so could walk
on water what he saying is that person
is so holy they're just like us it's a
way of like it's a little pejorative
it's like saying they're kind of a goody
goody two shoes kind of a thing but the
whole idea of walking on Waters is that
is that chaos itself is under his feet
yeah right you know that the the the
Lord who established the Earth upon the
waters as it says in the Psalms right it
has total dominance over the waves has
total dominance over the elements right
these these things that are the Abode of
death and chaos and the serpent all
these different things all those things
are under Christ's feet and this is the
idea in the icon of theophany where we
show him crushing the head of a serpent
in the waters this is in the Liturgy in
the Orthodox Church um I mean if you
want dragons in church like go to
baptism and or or or like the great
blessing of the waters right theophany
right and here just listen to the
prayers talking about asking asking God
right the god of Israel Jesus Christ to
come down and crush the heads of the
serpents in the waters right um and and
any dragon any unclean Spirit any of
those things that are lurking in water
as the the sort of like primordial
source of of chaos and instead uh reveal
the the the creative potential like the
The Good the the good side the good
potential of water to create and give
life and cleanse and he yeah there's so
many images of Christ where if you
understand the relationship between the
dragon and water and you know you can
see it obviously as Orthodox it's easier
to see because it's all there in the
prayers it's there in the icon and you
kind of get it but once you understand
that then you'll understand some of the
images for example that Christ always
has these two aspects to him on the one
hand he is dominating over chaos and on
that's on one hand on the other hand he
is also let's say giving himself to the
chaos to dominate it in the surprise
right so when in the story where Christ
goes and sleeps in the boat uh and then
comes out to master the waters like all
of that is relating to Jonah it's
relating to all these IM and it's it's
obviously you know showing what's going
to happen in terms of the death and
Resurrection uh that he can descend into
the he can go into the dragon's mouth B
basically enter into the dragon you know
that image that we have of the the
warrior that sacrifices himself and goes
into the Beast and then cuts it up from
the inside you see that in the the the
the iconography of St uh St Margaret um
you know that's that's it like that's
the imagy of Christianity but it is
related to the waters and the dragon all
comes together in death all these images
come together that's also the ending of
shark NATO by the way oh I haven't seen
shark so I'm really sorry to even bring
this up but there was this movie came
out many years ago um I think it was
like two houses ago or something for us
so a long time ago I had way fewer
children but this movie came out and it
was like the the idea was like just mash
up two 90s you know like mash up jaws
with Knight of the Twisters or something
like that kind of a thing and so like
there's this big tornado and it starts
dumping sharks everywhere and the sharks
are eating everybody it's a terrible
movie it's really dumb really bad but it
was funny how like uh in the end so I
sat down with my brother-in-law to watch
it as like kind of like a Mystery
Science Theater 3000 like like mock it
kind of a thing and uh it was really
interesting like at the end of the movie
the main character gets swallowed by a
shark and then he chainsaws his way out
and I even remember at the time thinking
like man you know even making a A Goofy
Movie that's that that was that was not
made with any intention of it being good
they just made this to make a dumb movie
just for the memes B you know uh uh but
but but even even at the end like they
couldn't get away from the Christian
symbolism right like cutting your way
out of the monster so yeah um yeah
really sorry everybody I didn't know I
was going to talk about that today
but um but I mean actually I mean the
movie Jaws right is a great example of
of really what is a Dragon Story yeah
right the idea of like the dragon
lurking in the depths now you could say
that uh well a a shark is a dragon it's
not even a reptile you know what are you
going on about etc etc right but but
it's function it's functioning in that
story it's functioning as a dragon yeah
well we can see like the the
representation of the monster that
swallowed up Jonah in in Tradition even
from like the second century image we
have one of the earliest images in
Christianity we have is of Jonah being
swallowed by that that uh that fish but
it's a it's basically a sea monster it's
a dragon really it's a sea dragon man
there's some crazy stuff about the about
Jonah in the services of the Orthodox
Church as well like if you go to matens
uh one of the Cannons that matens like
always has the theme of Jonah yeah Jonah
Matt Canon like every morning if you're
at a you know place where they're doing
matens every day right or you know at
least every Sunday at your church right
there will be at least one verse or set
of verses that on the theme of The Feast
but but it will work Jonah in there some
somehow and you know this idea of of um
you know the sea monster spewing out
Jonah like a babe from the womb right
and Christ raising up as a as a bride
Chamber from as as from a bridal chamber
like stuff like that is is wild stuff
yeah so so yeah um uh the the other
thing that I want to say though is that
there is
a there is a positive aspect to dragons
or at least this idea that you can take
some of the aspects of the Dragon it's
it's uh so so like to go back to the
hybrid right um hybrids are dangerous
right because of uh for various
different reasons right um but they're
also uh hybrids have a certain like
resilience to them right and in fact in
in uh animal husbandry and things like
that or or the whole horiculture the
whole idea of like hybrid resilience is
like if you get a strain of like a
species or a breed that's like two pure
bread um this happened with fruit trees
um it also happens with like modern like
dog breeds you know if you look at what
a German Shepherd looks like now as
opposed to what one looked like even 100
years ago you know it's really dramatic
difference um where where you you
selectively breed too long for these
very specific features right and then
what you lose as a result is everything
that made the breed strong and actually
capable of doing work right and so then
the question of well how do I get take
one of these you know you probably can't
take your cocker spaniel hunting for
instance right even though he's a bird
dog right uh probably not gonna probably
not going to work out um uh because he's
too fragile um uh my my parents own many
cocker spaniels when I was a kid and I
could just tell you they're very fragile
very neurotic animals right but wasn't
always so um and so you know so there is
a kind of like a strength and a
resilience to the idea of the hybrid um
also the dragon's capacity as a guardian
right if you're guarding
something uh you're only a threat to
what's on the outside but if you're on
the inside then you you actually want
that right and so lots and lots of
cultures and I mean lots and lots of
cultures pretty much every drag culture
that has a Dragon Story which is all of
them will use dragons in this kind of
app traic way um Welsh culture is a
great example it's my favorite example
because of course you know it's right on
the flag it's right on the coat of arms
it goes back to like the oldest stuff I
mean Arthur himself right pen Dragon
right head of a dragon right like like
he's um Arthur himself is associated
with dragon imagery over and against
right the Saxons right um and that that
that that early story like generation or
two before Arthur right of you know the
the white dragon the red dragon fighting
right you know beneath the castle and
eventually the red dragon is which is
the the the Welsh or the bonic dragon is
going to win the fight right and so um
uh but also lots and lots of dragon
stuff going on
in uh Germanic Iron Age culture Old
English Old Norse Etc um very common to
to put dragons on things like the crust
of a helmet yeah or the face of a Shield
or The prow of a ship right um and this
was stuff that just sort of like came
naturally to people like if I want this
to be scary to my enemies what would I
put on it the scariest thing that
anybody could imagine yeah right which
which is a dragon right and it's playing
with very this is playing with very very
deep symbolism that ends up in the
medical symbolism as well you know the
idea of you know I think I might have
mentioned this before the uh in the the
symbol of the serpent on the on the rod
the what's his name what's the name of
the god uh
cadus no it's not the cadus it's
a I'm going to think about it later it's
going to come to me anyways so the the
Roman god of the basically the Roman God
of healing he the story is that he he
kills the gorget which is this Dragon
kind of sea uh serpent monster and and
he takes the blood from the right side
of the serpent and makes yeah it's it's
it's hermas but it's it's called the the
the the the caduceus is the name but no
this is it's not the same this is this
is a different this is different healing
god with a with a snake yes it is I'm
sorry darn it I don't know why I I I
don't know why I don't know why his name
isn't coming to me I usually I've
written about this anyway it doesn't
matter um uh and so he takes the blood
from the right side of the serpent to
make healing but then the idea is that
the blood from the left side of the
serpent basically is the poison and so
this idea of this apotropaic function of
poison right as both that which kills
you or that which saves you is the is
the very symbolism of of medicine itself
right it's a it's it's using the poison
to create a cure out of the poison right
this idea of of uh of trampling death by
death basically of using death against
itself it's always been uh weird to me
as an aside how if you look at a lot of
ancient abstract imagery of the the
caducus or you anyway the rod you're
talking about um that uh it has um uh it
a lot ofus it's the rod of esus esus
okay right I'm such an idiot like I'm
like it's gonna come just send the
Google search on in my one days too it's
all right so uh yeah buffering please
wait but but when you look at um when
you look at uh abstract um versions of
it you you find in like Sumerian imagery
because it's there and it's in India as
well right that a lot of times abstract
it looks like a it looks like a DNA
Helix yeah which I've always thought is
a very interesting well that's a good
way to represent it like the caducan rod
is a good way to represent it instead of
just one you have two snakes basically
that they are right snake and a left
snake one that two are facing each other
like in in Conflict uh and in the in the
case of Hermes it really has to do with
the bridge it has to do with this in
between space that is a double-sided
space right it this is
Theus aspius has the one snake the r
caducus has the two guys you're watching
us just like figure this out but esus is
directly related to to healing in Roman
mythology whereas Hermes is is in some
way seen as this messenger figure yeah
but that it's related because the the
messenger the in between or the the the
bridge or the this is the problem of the
hybrid right it's like this in between
space that goes both ways it's like it
can either uh it could either be a
guardian or a you're right it could
either be something which is defining or
something which is going to bring bring
chaos right that's the Theus also
associated with RH was also associated
with like rhetoric it was the symbol of
of rhetoric in the ancient world I think
for the same for the same reason right
you know the capacity of Ric to sort of
heal or hurt you know um yeah yeah so
um we with this yes integrating I'm
sorry guys it's hard because dragons
will bring you all over the place that's
exactly what they do because they're
very the symbolism is quite is quite big
so um so when we're talking about like
integrating the aspects of the the
serpent or integrating the aspects of a
dragon right this is where um this is
why basically everybody that I've ever
talked to about doing this video that
we're doing right now will say something
like oh I'm really looking forward to
your symbolic world video on uh and I've
had like 10 people say this to me really
looking forward to the symbolic world
video on dragons because I don't
understand what's going on with Asian
dragons and why they're different you
know because they're obviously they're
very different because they're like good
luck and all these different things well
folks here it is they're the same
that's it they're the same thing um uh
if you go back and look at really early
like Bronze Age um uh Chinese dragons uh
they're usually sometimes called Pig
dragons or pigheaded dragons because
basically it's like a serpent usually
kind of curled up in a sort of a fetal
position but it's a serpent with the
head of a pig um and then it seems like
um
contact with the uh uh with the like the
Persian world via the Silk Road right so
anytime we're talking about anything
actually uh from this period you have to
understand there was a there was a very
very heavily used trade route between
China and Baghdad you know and and uh uh
you know and even before Baghdad was
Baghdad like the very heavily used trade
route between the ancient near East and
and there for eventually the Roman world
uh when that comes to develop but anyway
very very well-used trade route between
the ancient near East and the Far East
yeah
and what this means is that if if if you
think of these things to be like totally
different worlds it's not totally
accurate they they are in some ways but
but but they they actually share a lot
more than you would think so um it seems
like because of uh by the Iron Age
because of of contact with dragon
imagery in Persia and elsewhere um that
eventually the the the the Chinese
version of the Dragon comes into much
greater alignment with with that's why I
was saying earli if you look at a
picture of a of a Persian Dragon which
we'll put up here on the screen it looks
just like a Chinese dragon essentially
right and so then what eventually
happens in China is that you get two
forms they have two different names but
uh basically the main difference is one
has wings and the other one doesn't and
then eventually the wingless version
becomes predominant but if you go back
and you look at the very earliest
Chinese dragon stories which we have
recorded and we have some very old ones
because uh they were an incredibly
literate Society even from you know very
early time um their water their their
Guardian they're they are they are
Serpentine Spirits or deities or beings
who guard bodies of water and and then
sometimes this is what's interesting to
make also control the
rainfall um so Norm like in the what you
do have in the West in like the
indoeuropean version of the story is
that um
the uh uh the the the main enemy of the
Dragon is often the the Thunder God who
controls the rainfall and in China it's
the the sort of like the dragon is the
Thunder God sometimes yeah um but yeah
is a is a serpentine deity or Spirit or
being or monster that's a hybrid of all
these different kinds of animals and
controls these various bodies of water
and a lot of the early stories have to
do with not trying to slay the dragon
although there is one that I've one one
or two that I found although a lot of
the dragon slaying stories actually seem
to have come from Buddhism who
probably uh uh probably got them from
from India or maybe from uh uh the
Christian near East something like that
and then so in some like later Buddhist
mythology dragons do become
representative of these demons that
represent the passions and Etc but but
in the earliest stuff uh for the most
part uh instead of trying to slay the
dragon to get the water you're trying to
appease the dragon in some way with a
gift of some kind trying to appease the
dragon to get the water what eventually
happens and this is really important for
uh Chinese Cultural identity all the way
up to the to the revolution really is um
that the dragon becomes Associated
specifically with the emperor to the
point that it becomes illegal to um uh
for anybody that's not part of the
Imperial family to even use a dragon as
a symbol on anything um and then um and
there are there's whole different kinds
of things about um I mentioned earlier
there's a lot of symbolism for different
different kinds of dragon like certain
numbers of features and scales and spots
and things like this so there's like one
dragon that you would use if you were
the emperor and but then if you were
some member of the Imperial family but
not the emperor yourself there was
another dragon that you would get to use
but it wouldn't be like it wouldn't have
quite all the same features and so um
but basically the dragon became
synonymous with Imperial power right and
so in that same way that you can take
the aspect of the dragon and then kind
of harness it
right uh but then also there's also with
that there's always this this there's
always an aspect to a dragon of of its
potential to hoard or oppress yeah so so
you could imagine that the connection is
that if you see the the dragon as a
guardian of water you could understand
that as a guardian of blessings like you
could you could that could easily go
into that direction and so once you see
that then you can understand why the
the the guardian of the blessing the
guardian of waters could be like a sign
of good luck in that sense right it's
right that if I make the dragon happy
then I then it opens up the door so that
this stuff will come down on me right
and you can understand why that would
then end up being that could be related
to the Emperor or to some person of
authority because they are the guardians
of blessing the guardian of blessings
with the other really interesting thing
is um if you read a lot of old stuff
about dragons in Chinese and this is
still the case by the way in modern like
Asian organized crime is this idea that
if you put the image of the Dragon on
something but you're not worthy of it uh
actually you find the same kind of thing
in Scandinavian uh mythology and stuff
but if you if you put the if you put the
image of the Dragon on something but you
are not sufficiently Dragon like
yourself then it's not good luck it's
actually quite the opposite like the
dragon will consume you like if you if
you take the symbol of the Dragon for
yourself but you're not strong and and
and lucky and
you know all these things that a dragon
is right if you're not those things
enough then actually you'll get the the
wrong kind of attention from the dragon
um which is which I I think is the case
of like apotropaic imagery in general
right the idea that that uh you want to
make sure it's outward facing and if but
if you're not like Yourself Strong then
try to put yourself behind this thing
and sort of hide yourself behind it
it'll end up turning in on you and kind
of consuming and eating right and you
can understand that as the you know if
you think of curus or these kind of
marginal figures that are in between
spaces that guard the the guard the
world of death for example and they kind
of act they kind of act both ways
they'll stop they stop things from the
outside to come in but they can also
prevent you from going out if you're not
if you're not care careful and the the
the similarity between medieval
iconography Western medieval iconography
of demons and Western medieval
iconography of of gargoyles is exactly
that in some ways they very similar in
nature and one is facing out and the
other is coming towards you but it can
always that's why there's even an
ambiguous in modern kind of popular
culture there's an ambiguous uh
relationship to things like gargoyles
let's say you know where they're seeing
almost as ominous and evil because
they're on that they're on that edge you
know and so something to say as maybe
just like kind of a final note to this
is that there are plenty of examples in
Christian iconography of of
you you would think we would just always
be anti-dragon all the time but there
are plenty of examples of dragons again
cherubim and sarapin being a really easy
example right uh but there are sort of
like monsters that are on our side or
like the the idea of the monster
guarding Paradise I've been to lots of
Orthodox churches in more than one
country where uh on the on the holy
doors right the the holy doors in front
of the altar there would be like sort of
you know border patterns of dragons
right same thing in the Middle Ages
doors of churches um later on when pews
come in uh even like carvings on the
outside of pews and things like that
right so so this is this is actually and
of course lots of Christian countries
lots of Christian countries use dragons
as part of their they're massive dragons
on MOS uh you know on the iconostasis
and usually they're akin to the
symbolism of the bishop staff which is
that you'll usually have two dragons
under the cross kind of facing the cross
uh on the ionas if you have a cross the
top of it um you know and it I think it
is related to this but the the deepest
and most mysterious aspect of the
symbolism is the fact that Christ takes
the shape of a serpent on the cross that
is and that's where I wanted to end was
was and it starts with Moses lifting up
the serpent in the wilderness so he
takes the pole and puts the serpent on
it and of course going back to uh the
rod of aus or the caducus right you've
got uh this idea of like a serpent on a
pole as a source of healing as a source
of life right but that's in that's an
exodus yeah or numbers anyway it's it's
a yeah it's in numbers yeah it's in
numbers and and uh and Christ
says my crucifixion is like
this you know he says that that's it's
one of the times that the Bible
interprets the Bible for you which is
always handy you know like sometimes you
can like sit around and like really
think about these things and overthink
them a little bit but there are a a a a
precious few number of times where Jesus
will just tell you this is what this
thing means right and so he says even as
Moses lifted up the serpent in the
wilderness even so the must must the son
of man be lifted up right and if I am
lifted up when I am lifted up I will
draw all men to
me right and so this uh and so
um I said we were gonna stop here but
but kind of continuing kind of can go
ahead but I just want to say like yeah
to understand the mystery of Christ you
know you have to understand it or the
mystery of the god of Israel and how he
manifests himself in the world you have
to be able to see the three parts of
this story which is on the one hand
Christ is swallowed by the snake on the
one hand he becomes the snake and on the
on the one hand he kills the snake and
he does all three kind of simultaneously
on the cross uh which is very it's a I
mean it's it's one of those instances
where you know there's no story to tell
after that it's pretty much reach the
limit of what the symbolism of the snake
is there is this there is this kind of a
strange thing with the image of the
Dragon especially the winged dragon so
just talk about this varant for a moment
not every dragon has wings um that's is
if not like a universal but lots of
dragons have wings or can fly right uh
going back to like the Asian Dragon you
know they always they're always able to
fly right and this is why they can be
associated with the terrestrial water
and also the water that's from above
yeah um there is this kind of weird
thing with serpents and birds so this is
something that came up in the bolf class
that uh i' I I've just thought about a
lot since he talking about this idea
that you have in some old stories for
instance the the the story of fair who
who again is the sort of the
archetypical Old Norse Dragon this idea
that uh if you eat the heart of a dragon
you can understand the speech of birds m
right to understand the speech of birds
and the idea of the speech of birds is
always associated with let's say like
Heavenly wisdom right um so then like
what's what's going on there what's the
connection there and and as we were
talking about it uh I it occurred to me
um you know Christ
Command right be wise as serpents and
harmless as doves right that this is
connect this that this has to be that
this is connected in some way right yeah
that in some ways two actually if you
you could do them simultaneously yeah
yeah and uh and again that's like one of
those things that I still have not like
fully you know I don't know it's hard to
talk about because it's one of the
things like I have an intuition there
but it's not fully formed yeah it's
difficult because one of the things that
makes it difficult is that in some ways
this symbolism of the wing serpent for
example uh is one of the most is one of
the oldest and kind of the most
universal symbolism like you find these
the symbolism in north in like South
America when the the the Spanish and
North America and Egypt yeah it's really
everywhere and so it is in some ways a
you know it is this Union of Heaven and
Earth maybe it is this it's kind of
poking at certain imagery that's very
difficult to fully grasp and in and
because of what the dragon represents
you can kind of understand
how it can become
parasitical you know if it if you
understand it as a guardian it can
always be both affording and preventing
and it can always at the same time
become um how can I say this it can just
like the principalities in general that
say you imagine principalities above you
how they can afford Grace from above or
they can actually St make the grace stop
from at where they are that seems to be
one of the some of the symbolism that
that is being Shak up here okay so in
your recent conversation with Father
Joseph Lucas which was tremendous by the
way people should go back and listen to
it if they didn't listen because because
it was really really good but one of the
curious things in there St serel of
Alexandria when he's talking about the
the scapegoat right and he says Christ
being uh the the the scapegoat being
sent out into the Wilderness is like
Christ ascending to heaven and I
remember how weird that seemed right H
and and this is one of the frustrating
things about listening to your friends
you know and Father Joseph is a good
friend of mine and you're a good friend
of mine the really difficult thing about
listening to your friends have a
conversation but you're not actually
there for keep wanting to jump in yeah I
know and what I what I wanted to say
about that actually so this is me
jumping in what I wanted to say about
that actually is that that's a very
that's actually a relatively common
patristic interpretation you find the
same thing in St Gregory palamas who
lived a lot longer you know uh much
later than St s and the reason the
reason for this it goes back to this
idea like we we're used to like thinking
of the Wilderness as the Abode of the
Demons but also the air is the Abode of
the Demons yeah yeah yeah right the the
air is the air is the Abode of the
Demons right and so you have this idea
St Greg talks about of Christ sort of
like clearing a path for us as he's
ascending right clearing a path for us
so that we can pass sort of pass up
unharmed even I know it's like people
freak out if you imagine this but even
the idea of you know what I'm going to
say yeah we know what you're talking
about yeah that's what it's dealing with
the the houses that you have to kind of
encounter well in St Paul we in the on
Sunday's reading you know that's what it
it say yeah yeah it's talks about that
about exactly so I just I just like so
so but this is related to the idea of
the the fiery the the fiery flying
serpent right yeah this this idea that
that there are these kind of that there
there could be these like monstrous
principalities that guard not just uh
you know that guard access to Paradise
like I don't know how to say it you know
yeah and um uh and there's association
with their capacity to fly right and the
sort of access to I mean one of the one
of the tropes it doesn't always come up
but it often comes up with dragons and
going back to the idea of eating the
heart so you can understand the language
of birds is related to this is is uh a
lot of times dragons are considered to
be very wise or or have access to wisdom
or knowledge about things that humans
don't have right you find this in some
of like the uh zor asrian dragon stories
as well for instance so this idea that
this the idea that the dragon has access
to to this knowledge right but then of
course sometimes sometimes uh uh
sometimes knowledge is not good for you
right sometimes that wisdom is not good
for you so so it's got that kind of
ambiguity to it yeah no for sure I mean
we're not going to get out of the
ambiguity we in the symbolism of the
Dragons because I'm thinking again now
like the way that the dragon represented
in Revelation you know as the great this
great dragon that pulls the stars that
pulls the principalities and captures
them basically under his rule um you
know it's like okay there's another
image of how he's hoarding he's hoarding
these angels in his grasp and now he's
you know kind of mastering them for his
own for his own will um you know there's
another image that's very similar uh but
now the dragon is definitely represent
in in all the Revelation the dragon is
definitely the devil he's not yes there
no question at all that's right so so I
think that it's it's really I think
we're we're still we're back at the
beginning yeah in the sense that you
know if someone thought they would come
here uh and get a dictionary definition
of what a dragon is not GNA happen yeah
but here's here's the thing about
dragons though if you see one you know
it that's you know it's one of the
things like very hard to nail down a
definition across the board but I can
look at a a dragon in a Chinese image
yeah and I can look at uh uh the the
carving of the midgard serpent on the
door of a church in Norway and I can
look at you know a a a Persian
illumination of a dragon and I can look
at uh you know something from South
America and I can look at all of those
things and say that's a dragon that's a
dragon that's right yeah yeah all right
everyone well that's our discussion
about Dragon thanks everybody for your
attention and and uh and I think that
both of us both Richard and I were still
yeah still processing and still
processing the discussion and so uh get
involved in the commentaries this is the
time you know tell us your your uh your
insights about Dragon so thanks
everybody we'll talk to you soon thanks
everyone